et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Carole Delga bonjour Carol Belga merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous depuis
Toulouse vous êtes la présidente de
cette région Occitanie présidente
socialiste et présidente de région de
France et on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes on va bien sûr parler de votre
actualité dans la région
Occitanie vous réunissez des milliers de
mer on en parle dans quelques instants
mais d'abord l'actualité nationale et la
question de l'immigration puisqu'elle
Isabelle borne a donc annoncé que
finalement elle allait demander à Gérald
Darmanin de reprendre les consultations
en vue d'un texte qui serait présenté en
juillet en conseil des ministres est-ce
que pour vous c'est un texte nécessaire
bonjour non ce n'est pas un texte
nécessaire je pense qu'en France il y a
des urgences des urgences qui sont
sociales c'est pouvoir redonner du
pouvoir d'achat aux classes qui sont
très très impactés par l'inflation il y
a les urgences sur l'éducation nationale
sur l'hôpital et la santé et je ne
comprends pas cet acharnement à vouloir
mener à tout prix Une loi sur
l'immigration et puis moi je tiens à
rappeler que l'immigration est une
chance pour notre pays et qu'il faut
arrêter de stigmatiser les immigrés
travaillant sur les vrais problèmes de
la France avec une meilleure répartition
des richesses et avec des services
publics qui sont renforcés et qui ne
sont plus laminées comme c'est le cas
pour l'éducation nationale ou la santé
mais pour vous le gouvernement
stigmatise les immigrés il y a dans ce
texte toute une partie par exemple avec
cette mesure qui est une régularisation
des titres de séjour des travailleurs
dans les métiers en tension il y a rien
de bon dans ce texte
dans le débat qui il y a autour de des
l'immigration il y a quand même je
trouve un biais qui est plutôt négatif
il faut rappeler que la France elle
s'est construite à travers la rencontre
d'hommes et de femmes qu'il y a bien sûr
une richesse culturelle qu'il y a aussi
une richesse économique et je pense que
on doit avoir un discours beaucoup plus
clair sur les apports positifs de
l'immigration rappeler bien entendu que
en France nous devons respecter les lois
que la devise républicaine doit être
respectée avec le principe de laïcité
c'est à dire que la loi est au-dessus de
la foi mais sur ce sujet de
l'immigration je trouve que les propos
sont souvent négatifs et que surtout il
n'y a pas
urgence à légiférer sur ce sujet
à réforme des retraites les espoirs des
opposants sont désormais tournés vers
cette date du 8 juin ou sera examiné à
l'Assemblée le texte d'abrogation de la
réforme des retraites vous pensez
vraiment que cette loi sera abrogée ou
c'est un faux espoir qu'on est en train
de donner à des milliers de Français
mon message sur la réforme de retraite
c'est pour le président de la République
il faut qu'il entendent la colère du
peuple il faut qu'il entend de ce
sentiment d'injustice qu'il y a chez les
Français et donc c'est à lui un
responsabilité de ne pas appliquer cette
loi qui qui l'a promulgué il faut qu'il
ait une responsabilité une volonté
d'apaisement parce que ces deux ans ces
deux ans de trop pour celles et ceux qui
ont commencé à travailler tôt pour les
femmes pour celles et ceux qui ont des
métiers pénibles il ne se rend pas
compte Emmanuel Macron la pénibilité du
travail quand on est charpentier quand
on est au fond d'une tranchée quand on
soigne des gens dans des maisons de
retraite dans des hôpitaux il doit
vraiment arrêter ce sentiment qu'on les
Français d'être méprisés parce que nous
allons avoir des tensions de plus en
plus fortes dans ce pays il faut apaiser
il faut faire une pause et c'est mon
appel pour le président de la République
de ne pas s'entêter comme il le fait il
faut justement rassembler les Français
les rassurer et c'est de sa
responsabilité de ne pas continuer sur
cette réforme des retraites qu'est-ce
que vous entendez par tension de plus en
plus forte Carole d'Elga qu'est-ce que
vous redoutez jusqu'où ça peut mener
pour vous
je crains qu'il y ait des violences et
on ne peut pas continuer à avoir un
discours qui est sourd de cette
inquiétude moi sur le terrain j'y suis
tous les jours j'entends toutes ces
personnes qui travaillent durement qui
n'arrivent pas à vivre de leur revenu du
travail de façon digne j'entends aussi
ces agriculteurs qui sont excédés par
design jonctions qui sont
contradictoires j'entends ces jeunes qui
sont très angoissés par le réchauffement
climatique qui se disent mais qu'elle va
être mon avenir et je pense que nous
devons vraiment avoir un temps de
concorde un temps de rassemblement et
que cette réforme doit être stoppée
parce que nous avons vraiment une une
inquiétude une possibilité d'expression
violente que nous devons éviter à tout
prix cela demande l'exercice du pouvoir
de la responsabilité de l'écoute et de
savoir renoncer ou temporiser vous
parlez des violences l'Assemblée
nationale a décidé hier de créer une
commission d'enquête justement sur les
groupuscules auteurs de violence à
l'occasion des manifestations entre le
16 mars et le 3 mai ça veut dire que ça
concerne également les manifestations à
Sainte Soline les manifestations du 1er
mai c'est une bonne idée
oui c'est une bonne idée dans tous les
cas on ne doit jamais jamais cautionner
la violence et ne pouvons pas rester
immobile par rapport à ces dérives les
manifestations doivent toujours se
dérouler dans l'ordre et le calme et
dans toutes les manifestations liées aux
retraites moi je salue l'esprit de
responsabilité des organisations
syndicales qui ont fait pour que cette
expression elle soit toujours Pacifique
vous parlez du réchauffement climatique
Carole Delga il y a des inquiétudes dans
le pays évidemment lié à la sécheresse
et particulièrement dans un des
départements de votre région les
Pyrénées-Orientales qui ont été placés
en alerte Chris sécheresse c'est le plus
haut niveau d'alerte au moins jusqu'au
13 juin ça veut dire qu'il y a des
nouvelles restrictions vous soutenez ces
mesures elles étaient inéluctables pour
vous
elles étaient malheureusement
inéluctables parce qu'il a très très peu
plus depuis un an dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales je m'y suis rendue
il y a quinze jours j'ai annoncé qu'il y
aurait un fond exceptionnel de la part
de la région d'un million d'euros et je
suis en contact bien sûr avec le préfet
avec l'ensemble des élus des
agriculteurs qui sont vraiment très
inquiets sur les productions agricoles
et tout particulièrement
arboricole et donc on doit prendre des
pour bien sûr l'eau potable pour la
consommation humaine mais aussi pour
l'eau productive faire en sorte que les
bêtes dans le cadre de l'élevage est
toujours de l'eau à boire et que les
arbres fruitiers ne meurent pas et
puissent avoir minimum de production et
nous avons appelé avec la présidente du
département des Pyrénées-Orientales à ce
qu'il y ait un fond exceptionnel décidé
par de solidarité pour bien sûr les
agriculteurs mais également pour les
acteurs touristiques qui vont être
fortement touchés parce que bien entendu
l'eau pour des activités de loisirs ne
sera pas prioritaire vous avez créé un
fond vous dans votre région est-ce que
en tant que présidente de région de
France vous travaillez avec d'autres
présidents de région pour créer un fond
plus large face à cette sécheresse qui
risque de toucher une très grande partie
du territoire
j'ai repris président de région en effet
réfléchissent à créer un fond en
fonction de la réalité donc de
sécheresse dans dans leur région mais ce
qu'il est nécessaire c'est qu'il y ait
avant tout un Fond national décidé par
le gouvernement et les régions nous
serons à leur côté nous agirons mais
l'action des régions n'exonère pas le
gouvernement de la nécessaire solidarité
nationale mais que vous dit le
gouvernement là-dessus
le gouvernement a annoncé plusieurs
dispositifs mais je pense qu'il n'est
pas encore à la hauteur du risque
vraiment d'effondrement de la production
agricole donc il y a eu des premiers pas
le ministre de l'Agriculture est venu
ces derniers jours mais je pense qu'il
va y avoir la nécessité d'augmenter les
budgets qui sont annoncés pour la
solidarité pour ce territoire catalan
les Pyrénées-Orientales qui sont
touchées par de nouveaux incendies ces
dernières heures est-ce que vous pouvez
nous faire un point sur la situation ce
matin
nous avons en fait plus de 1100 hectares
qui ont qui ont brûlé donc dans les
Pyrénées-Orientales avec dans certains
territoires comme cerbère vraiment un
paysage de désolation la situation est
vraiment sous surveillance accrue
maximale parce que il y a en fait une
sécheresse très très forte sur
l'ensemble des végétaux et donc une
possibilité de s'embraser très
facilement et surtout il y a aussi du
vin donc je tiens à saluer l'effort de
surveillance de l'ensemble des autorités
de sécurité publique voilà des pompiers
de l'ensemble des forces de l'ordre et
surtout j'appelle à la responsabilité
citoyenne de ne pas aller fumer dans des
endroits où la nature est présente et
encore moins de faire des barbecues des
choses comme ça donc il faut avoir une
responsabilité citoyenne très très forte
parce que trop
d'incendie sont partis d'un mégoté un
mot sur une actualité qui concerne
région de France la Présidente de la
Région Île-de-France Valérie Pécresse a
saisi le tribunal administratif il y a
quelques semaines parce qu'elle estime
que le procédé actuel de péréquation
entre les régions des avantages les
Franciliens c'est-à-dire le
rééquilibrage financier entre les
régions est-ce que ce principe de
péréquation de solidarité est juste
selon vous est-ce qu'il faut le réformer
il y a eu un principe de péréquation qui
avait été mis en place donc il y a de ça
maintenant 13 ans suite à la suppression
de la taxe professionnelle mais il y a
eu une dernière modification il y a de
ça deux ans et il est un effet
nécessaire d'avoir un travail de fond
sur la péréquation mais dans tous les
cas la réforme de la taxe
professionnelle à avait donné un surplus
de ressources à la région
Île-de-France qui abrite beaucoup de
sièges sociaux il était logique qui est
une péréquation ce que demande Valérie
Pécresse c'est que cette équation qui a
été modifiée il y a de ça deux ans soit
revu dans un esprit qui soit complet par
rapport au dernier modification sur un
particulier la CVAE mais vous la
comprenez ça démarre le fait qu'elle est
saisi le tribunal administratif elle
vous en avez averti
oui Valérie Pécresse nous en avait
averti et avait bien expliqué que ce
travail qu'elle avait demandé que nous
avions demandé nous aussi les régions
auprès du gouvernement n'ayant pas
abouti elle a vraiment souhaité porter
ce sujet devant le tribunal
administratif et il y a une totale
transparence dans l'action de Valérie
Pécresse par rapport au gouvernement
Carla vous réalisez vous réunissez
pardon aujourd'hui des milliers de mer
d'Occitanie à Toulouse vous l'avez fait
avant-hier à Montpellier quel est
l'objectif de ces rencontres
l'objectif de ces rencontres c'est tout
d'abord de leur démontrer à ces mères
qui font un travail formidable que la
région est assez cotée et puis à leur
côté et puis de aussi de les réunir
réunir de leur démontrer que nous sommes
une force une force ensemble c'est plus
de 800 mères qui étaient à Montpellier
avant-hier ce matin ce sera plus de 1000
maires et c'est aussi l'occasion de leur
expliquer les politiques de soutien de
la Région je n'avais pas pu le faire
avant de parler conditions sanitaires et
là c'est la possibilité pour les mères
de mieux comprendre de mieux connaître
les politiques régionales de par ma
présentation de part aussi le village de
l'ensemble des services de la région où
chaque maire va pouvoir venir avec son
projet et avoir une réponse indirecte et
puis pour moi c'est aussi l'occasion
d'entendre
plusieurs attentes dont je suis beaucoup
sur le terrain mais là en deux jours je
vais rencontrer près de 2000 maires et
ils vont me faire par vraiment de leur
ressenti et de leurs besoins d'aide et
ça va me permettre d'ajuster aussi des
politiques régionales que nous allons
voter d'ici la fin d'année je pense en
particulier à la politique du logement
et de l'habitat durable et qu'est-ce qui
vous dit ces maires puisque vous les
avez déjà rencontrés à Montpellier quels
sont leurs principales préoccupations
leurs principales préoccupations c'est
tout d'abord le climat vraiment
d'anxiété qu'il y a dans la population
dont je vous parlais tout à l'heure il
le ressentent ils sont d'ailleurs
malheureusement souvent
agressé et je pense à ce maire de
Loire-Atlantique qui en arrive à
démissionner parce que voilà l'extrême
droite année à incendier une partie de
sa maison ou de ses véhicules il me
explique aussi qu'il y a beaucoup de
normes beaucoup de
complexité et qu'il faut vraiment
essayer de
simplifier donc les dossiers
administratifs y compris pour pour la
région et nous en Occitanie il me parle
particulièrement de la du sujet des
mobilités parce que nous sommes la
région la plus enclavée de France et
nous sommes une grande région sur 13 que
nous avons besoin à la fois de grandes
infrastructures de transport que ce soit
à travers les LGV ou à travers
l'amélioration de route en particulier
sur le massif central mais aussi de
remettre du train comme on a pu le faire
sur la rive droite du Rhône ou comme
nous allons le faire l'année prochaine
dans les Pyrénées et puis c'est la
question d'accueillir ces nouvelles
populations et nous avons la progression
démographique métropolitaine la plus
forte en France c'est 42 000 nouveaux
habitants donc il faut créer du travail
et puis il faut aussi créer du logement
et c'est un sujet qui est très très fort
avec aussi l'implantation des services
publics est-ce que c'est aussi une
manière de faire entendre votre voix au
niveau national est-ce que l'Occitanie
est aussi un tremplin pour vous
l'Occitanie est une région importante
pour pour la France c'est 10% de sa
population nous avons mis en oeuvre
depuis maintenant 7 ans nouveau modèle
de développement et je pense que en
effet les politiques gouvernementales
devraient plus s'inspirer de ce qui se
fait localement dans des communes dans
des départements dans des régions en
Occitanie nous avons mis en place la
gratuité des transports scolaires la
fourniture est des ordinateurs et des
manuels scolaires pour nos lycéens et
également la tarification du train la
plus faible de France avec le train à 1
euro sur l'année 2022
sur le plan national vous vous faites
entendre vous faites entendre votre voix
politiquement parlant notamment au sein
du Parti socialiste quels sont
aujourd'hui vos relations avec Olivier
fort est-ce que vous vous sentez encore
à l'aise dans ce parti socialiste tant
votre ligne divergent avec celle du
premier secrétaire
je suis vraiment toujours en fidélité
aux valeurs socialistes bien sûr à
l'héritage de Jean Jaurès originaire
d'Occitanie après ils peuvent parler
franchement
je n'ai pas de relation avec Olivier
Faure depuis le mois de janvier il
écarte toute celles et tous ceux qui ne
pensent pas comme lui au sein par
exemple du secrétariat national et donc
il ne me contacte pas ni moi ni bien
d'autres voilà c'est très dommageable
que
Olivier Faure ne veuille parler qu'à
tout juste 50% des socialistes mais
voilà il faut regarder loin et avoir
espoir qui soit enfin dans une volonté
de rassemblement et non pas dans une
volonté clanique regardez loin ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire regarder 2027
il faut regarder loin c'est à dire faire
en sorte que la République elle reste
debout et il faut avoir de la
responsabilité par rapport à la montée
de l'extrême droite et par rapport aux
politiques injuste et menée par Emmanuel
Macron c'est pourquoi ce qui se fait en
occitanisme par exemple sur la question
de la gratuité des transports scolaires
sur la question du train à 1 euro ça
doit nous inspirer à nous le Parti
socialiste pour faire de vrais
propositions pour donner plus de pouvoir
d'achat pour s'engager pleinement dans
la transition écologique par les
transports en commun et on doit faire
des vrais propositions pour le peuple de
gauche aujourd'hui le peuple de gauche
il est orphelin d'un projet de société
donc travaillons ensemble je dis il faut
regarder loin que ne porte plus le Parti
socialiste aujourd'hui que ne porte plus
partie socialiste se projette de société
mais aujourd'hui il n'y a pas assez de
travail au sein du Parti socialiste
quand je vois tous les débats toutes les
petites phrases qu'il y a au sein de la
gauche c'est incroyable de ne pas se
mettre autour d'une table de ne pas
travailler pour un vrai projet de
société parce que la République elle est
menacée par les idées de l'extrême
droite on voit que de toutes ces
séquences de cacophonie qui ont existé
ces derniers mois pendant la nassemblée
nationale la seule bénéficiaire elle
s'appelle Marine Le Pen et on continue à
parler de sujets accessoires et à ne pas
proposer un vrai projet de société pour
les Français en faisant une révolution
dans l'éducation nationale en donnant
plus de temps pour nos élèves en ayant
une vraie formation une meilleure
rémunération de nos enseignants en ayant
aussi un hôpital public qui soit soutenu
et qui ne soit pas jugé à l'homme de
juste de l'activité et puis on a besoin
aussi d'un vrai projet
européen où on rappelle que l'Europe
c'est notre avenir et c'est la solution
à nos problèmes est-ce que vous avez
envie de le portez-vous ce projet Carole
d'alga est-ce que vous avez envie de
sortir du Parti socialiste de créer un
mouvement à gauche pour porter ce projet
il faut quand même un moment être lucide
aujourd'hui la problématique c'est pas
l'ambition d'une personne quelle qu'elle
soit la problématique c'est de répondre
au sentiment d'injustice ou sentiment de
désespérance des Français qui se
dirigent de plus en plus vers l'extrême
droite et comment répondre on répond
avec des solutions concrètes et des
solutions concrètes cela veut dire
travailler bien connaître la réalité
traiter ces sujets là et proposer des
réformes des réformes pour plus de
justice sociale pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique et donc c'est
pas la question de Pierre Paul Jacques
ou Carole de ce qu'ils veulent faire
c'est la question de se rassembler et
c'est pour ça qu'au sein du Parti
socialiste voilà j'appelle à ce qu'il y
ait un rassemblement qu'on arrête ces
attitudes ridicules d'exclusion de la
part donc de la direction du Parti
socialiste autour de qui ce Carole celle
de la gauche et au sein de la gauche il
faut travailler ensemble il faut se
mettre au travail arrêtant de parler de
l'accessoire ayant un vrai projet de
société est-ce qu'il faut aussi se
détacher de la France insoumise
mais la France insoumise s'ils veulent
être autour de la table ils sont les
bienvenus et avec vraiment des principes
qui sont intangibles c'est-à-dire que
nous devons avoir foi dans le projet
européen et que
l'Europe n'est pas une forfaiture
démocratique sur le fait que nous devons
toujours travailler au rassemblement et
pas à l'exclusion et que nous ne devons
avoir aucune tolérance vis-à-vis de
communautarisme et ensuite d'avoir un
investissement massif dans la question
de l'éducation nationale de la santé la
question des énergies renouvelables et
que nous puissions également avoir un
investissement fort dans les transports
en commun et dans le dans le rail et je
porte par exemple aussi comme projet
qu'on est un Airbus du ferroviaire à
l'échelle européenne c'est avoir un
grand géant industriel européen qui nous
permettra d'agir clairement pour le rail
pour la transition écologique sur
l'ensemble des marchés du monde mais
également d'avoir une souveraineté
industrielle forte merci Carole Delga
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous
depuis Toulouse et merci à Nadia
Bertrand qui nous a permis de réaliser
cette interview depuis Toulouse merci
beaucoup on passe au club des
territoires